[Music]
run
why do you think there are more decisive
games in this match then will
Championship matches in the past
I guess the reason is maybe we are not
that that professional than Magnus
[Music]
we appreciate that I'm gonna get it done
and Black's pieces look amazing he's
coordinating everything defends each
other there's a capture on D6 now Bishop
F4
queen queen
a mate on H1 how do you stop it stop it
that's a spectacular shot winning the
game the game is over it's two amazing
retreating moves and it's over Magnus
can resign phenomenal fantastic simply
fantastic what the best
this is chess I can't even remember the
first game the first three games of the
playoffs wow
[Music]
[Applause]
our singfield Cup champion ding Loren uh
sorry can you speak your question again
this history if Queen H6 take take and
look H3 to save wow saves the day so
there's no Queen G7 made because of the
check on F2
very promising
oh after Rook City Rook takes F7 you're
saying yeah King takes a seven and queen
season 7 made
that may be the reason why he didn't say
rookie too take take then look G7
very nice intermediate move and then
takes the Rook
beautiful
all right thank you so much and good
luck for tomorrow
much better comparing to the first two
days since I
moved to a new hotel I get some fresh
air
and yes the life became more beautiful
after that
so you moved to another hotel because
you wanted to open Windows right yes yes
okay which was generally favored almost
75-25 for Hikaru before the match
started that one crushing win with black
and
yeah and Hikaru shaking his head here is
the queen almost trapped uh by Knight B5
both Rooks attacked it's a position
where it's hard not to resign even
it's white okay he does it even better
job brings his Queen to the seventh
round Conquering the seventh Rank and
I've noticed when he's confident he
always has a sick of this massive bottle
of water you know so uh we have a result
it's over
ding Lee ran you guys beats world
champion Magnus Carlsen world number one
look at ding look at that posture that's
the posture of someone who who sees
something and is trying to figure it out
right yes yeah Bingo it's over wow hold
on I'm over I think ding just went for
it so the exchange sack and nipple looks
a little bit surprised it looks a little
bit taken aback by that but he's got to
have seen Knight B3 now sure and Knight
B3 so is the point and basically your
night well if you get the pawn and you
get your knight in here then it's
definitely the game over well things
walking away yeah things walking away
um yeah feeling pretty good about his
position
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
rahoe